well ladies and gentlemen one thing that
I've learned from the slammer guys is
that I thoroughly enjoy watching Dan get
hit in the face with stuff down how'd
you feel about that I really enjoy it
yeah I actually liked it so much it
makes me want to celebrate every time
that it happens so I thought today kill
two birds with one stone and injure down
and celebrate in the same go now one
thing I'm worried about is this cork is
going to fire out of this at high speed
high speed and what I'm worried about is
the cup might bounce off your head and
hit me in the eye so if now be terrible
what I'm gonna do is wear some safety it
goals check my eyes from this do I get
it you want some what's up yeah that one
yeah let's get on with it
oh oh no oh oh no oh that's really
distracting my son my face oh right II
the face ah the side the jawbone
ah
now upon review it appears that the cork
hit right ah on the side of the goggles
so tell me we have to do it again it
does thankfully we do that backups gonna
yeah I know you want yeah you might want
to kill some of the pain with that so
this one I'm gonna try knave a bit lower
right in your chops Kirby here we go
tension is definitely yeah I like it
oh crap oh you shaking it Oh God
all right on the cheek color ah how do
you get on my bone every time I like to
do everything in threes so we did get a
third I know that we'll already nailed
his cheek right there but uh let's go
for another one why not ah stop it
bloody dudes come on
how's that then yeah really nice liked
it so on these taste it can you like
reshape them together
still tastes good horrible hmm just that